it all right everybody welcome to
another business QA while we play League
of Legends super pumped to be here let
me change my camera there we go uh I
shaved so I'm excited about that well
Nina's more excited than i am but Nina's
excited about there I've got my usual
co-host du jour we should cut TV Rishi
welcome aboard if you say how is this
door yes I love that ok hi guys I'm
happy to be here this morning happy to
be with you go I'm really excited to get
to your question I love it what is in
the cup today you know Evan I'm
fulfilling today just so I'm cup of I
know that I say gratitude a lot but what
I'm specifically grateful for today is
just that every single day we make all
kinds of crazy mistakes reducing wrong
but we have the opportunity to keep
learning and keep growing and get up
again and try again and I really really
appreciate it for that today so I love
it we've got Jay rise in the game with
me I'm gearing up for jungle he's min so
we'll see how we get it I am I'm sadly
out of nettle tea I gotta go buy some
more so I'm having some yogi something T
and the message i love the message
today's i was a message your head must
bow to your heart oh that is your
message i've heard you say that message
yeah i guess those exact words but yeah
I've been saying that for years so I'm i
was super pumped to uh I like yogi tea a
little bit more now I didn't hire yeah
but I'm liking the message so it's good
you know did you know that there is a
team called Rishi tea well we have to
try that out I'm gonna have to they
don't spell it right though they spell
it re Shi ok they don't smell it right I
like that don't smell it right
and I like that I used to have a intern
at my company named Maria but the she
had a silent J in there so Marie and
then J amery job but it was Maria and I
just got used to it that I can't spell
Moorea without automatically putting the
J in there Oh interesting yeah that's
like that's the right way to spell it I
guess took me a while to break that
habit just so used to having someone on
my team anyway let's do a quick shout
out to some of the people on twitch
before we get started we got Jen so much
hey y'all so forged 2453 welcome aboard
I think it's a new one wants me to play
Poppie I don't play papi sorry about
that I play team 0 0 and said everyone
had and sometimes heimerdinger but I
mean I'm going to hopefully get some
chemo today I want to give a quick shout
to Martin as well who was watched some
of these streams and last night gave me
some tips on my team Oh play changing my
item build around and some of my
strategy so I man i'm gonna hopefully do
him proud in today's game in China oh I
try to apply some of the Martin tips so
we'll see he's uh he's a player from
Europe and was up till two thirty in the
morning or whatever his time giving me
tips so I gotta I gotta do it oh yeah
not doing proud alright well we are
waiting for a game to start while we do
that why don't we get it to our first
question okay sounds great all right
first question comes from I you she and
I you see is a student from India and he
says I have a doubt not a question well
it's kind of question I think you're
going to see but he says you failed many
times in professional exam of becoming a
chartered accountant he says is there
something i'm lacking did you get the
question of it don't make sure i made it
clear ok are
so yeah this is a little I'm just going
to say that I thought immediately of a
friend of mine who was in a medical
school and he was being he was pursuing
this medical career because his you know
his parents really wanted him to pursue
this career and he just he just went
through the ringer because he wasn't
really I think naturally very gifted at
this particular niche of the field and
so he took exam after exam after exam
after damn and just failed and failed
and failed and it was like his health
went in decline and me it was just I
think one of the most stressful
situations he'd ever been to in life and
it was really a lot out of wanting to
just you know do right by his parents
and have that successful career in the
medical field but in time he learned
that there was another area of the
medical field that he was passionate so
I think he stayed in that industry but
he changed because of you know kind of
realizing that he kept hitting this wall
and it just wasn't working so you said
you failed many times I you see I'm not
suggesting that it's time for you to
switch industries or change but I think
a question you can ask yourself in the
midst of this is you know in your
pursuit of being a chartered accountant
ask yourself why are you failing do you
know why is it is it because you really
don't like what you do you don't like a
you know the field or is it something
that you need to just work even harder
because you love it just that much
whenever you come up against constant
failure I think it's a good time to ask
yourself what what needs to change and
and maybe you can ask people around you
to to help you at your actual school
yeah awesome I think back to reach she's
coming at the start of the
episode where she is grateful for the I
forget the exact words but the ability
to fail and start over again and I one
would I I echo a lot of what Rishi says
I agree what I would add to it is I
would question if it is for me I with
questioning tent-like are you doing it
because your parents want you two are
you doing it because it's something that
you really deeply meaningfully want to
become a chartered accountant you know
at some point we all have to make that
turning point in our lives where we
decide that I'm gonna do what I want to
do I'm gonna live my life I'm not going
to live what other people want me to do
and it's usually it's usually parents
like parents want you to do this or have
expectations you to do something and
that may be fine but you you won't ever
do great amazing things if you're not
living your truth and you're living your
life through other people's eyes so i
would i would definitely put that out on
the table and maybe now is the time to
really think about that and potentially
go somewhere else if it is something
like this is for you and you really want
to be a chartered accountant and is your
dream and nobody else's what the
constant failure of a test like some
people are really bad at tests are some
people you know they don't score well
but they still have the passion what
what it means what I take from it is you
don't fit well inside that box and it
may mean that chartered accountant is
still for you but you're gonna have to
find your own way to do it for you to
have success against all the other chart
of accountants just just general too but
especially for someone who's not not
doing well inside the rules not doing
well inside the box I'm going to have to
find a different way to
stand out and be successful so maybe
there's one part of Chartered Accountant
that you really are passionate about and
not a bunch of the other stuff you know
looking at your test scores are you
acing one part and kind of sucking and
everything else it just made me that you
need to you need to create an escape
plan for yourself out of that box it
could still be within chartered
accountant if that is your dream but you
can't do it like everybody else because
you're not having success doing it like
everybody else you got to find a way to
make it your own I don't know what that
is maybe you don't yet either but ask
some questions might help you explore
and be able to find it I think about one
of the only jobs that I ever had I had
to do data entry and I hated it but I
was the best present I was the best
person on my team because i never took
breaks i didn't take a lunch break in
and have a lunch out of everybody else
um but they had problems with me uh you
know snacking and listening to music in
the headphones while I was working oh
yeah I have not told this story uh I've
never heard it very yeah I had like I
had I had because I didn't go out to eat
lunch i ate at my desk while working and
they wouldn't let me listen to music
while doing super boring data entry
stuff and so I had to my solution was I
would always wear turtlenecks and I said
way at the back of the office like in
the last cubicle oh I gotta pick my my
t-mo jungle here nice and i would get i
would get a discman back in the days of
discman and put that on the floor and
then run a wire through my jeans through
my turtleneck I had to get an extra-long
headphone and then just have a little
bit of it popping out of my turtleneck
into my one year
and I almost got fired but then they
looked at my results and I was doing I
did more work than the other people on
my team combined like five or six of us
oh my god but it was still like okay
well we'll we'll keep him uh-huh but
that's a second environment right like
I'm destroying everybody on my team you
can't handle the fact that I want to
listen to the music in eat in the office
yeah um and it's fine like that might be
the culture the rules that they have and
whatever it's just that box didn't fit
me and I could force myself to stay
there and work harder or do things that
I didn't want to do but it would never
lead to me being great or discovering my
greatness it would never happened so I
had to break free and and get out of
that box and go do something else and so
that that's a question start asking
yourself when you see that you're up
against failure consistently or you're
frustrated consistently it may mean that
you quit and go to something else or if
you have a deep passion for it and it
may mean you just need to find a
different way to stand you gotta you
gotta break out of that box and do
something else that is different than
what everybody else is doing I think a
lot of people go through that I know a
lot of it might be afraid to try to
create their own thing to that is
different let us support their level of
genius but the alternative is you just
stay in this you know maybe safe thing
but that doesn't yield happiness for you
and you'll you'll just constantly be
living a mediocre life which which sucks
you've got to find the thing that you
can be great at and i'm going to start
applying it that's what I got ah yeah
we've got some comments in the chat done
so much thing yeah totally sucks when
your environment isn't
right and just interesting how much you
know you really are affected like being
in one job and you feel like there's a
roof over you feel like you have a
ceiling over you and you're boxed in and
then you can go to another place and
feel like you can reach your fullest
potential and so it's not to be
underestimated for sure yeah and it's
scary it's scary to leave the unknown to
go do something else but good is the
enemy of great I really think you should
do a video about that story you haven't
already oh really I feel like I've
talked him out of it maybe I haven't I
mean I yeah maybe yeah could be a good
one so I am Timo jungle okay Jay rises
back to his pantheon from yesterday the
experiment continues he's playing mid so
hey let's see how we do I gotta make
Martin proud okay come on alright our
next question comes from submit and
assume it says I already have made a
plan of my business but I don't know
where to start alright so this how do I
start questions is something that we get
a lot here and I think they'd answer is
just so a kind of simple but it's true
and that is you just have to start
because even the best plan is going to
be very different once you start
executing and so the only way to really
know whether the business is providing
value is by doing and by actually
getting out there and providing whatever
is your product or service so it's great
that you have a plan and now I would
just say can you start putting it into
some form of action right
unfortunately don't have information on
the business but is there a way that you
can start providing value today where
you are yeah there's no one place to
start there's no one place to start off
they reset my Craig's any item my
teammates didn't do a great job help me
here um it's just started right like
that sounds like maybe stupid advice but
there is no one optimal best place to
start you just start and then you keep
going and what that may help with is for
like if you're a perfectionist you want
it to be perfect you don't want to make
mistakes you wanted you know to be
amazing understanding that that's how
you just go and just keep adjusting and
then make improvements and do something
else tomorrow if you have a plan then
your plan has action steps right so the
plant does is here's what I'm going to
do so perfect start following your plan
and if one thing doesn't work out then
you do the next thing on the plan if
that doesn't work out then you go to
plan B and you make a new plan um a lot
of times the plan that you start with is
not going to be what you end up well J
reyez got first blood good job first
kill the game that Jay I'm like hey yeah
good good start good start I'm feeling
it like the worst thing you can do is is
just not take action it's better to take
action that doesn't work then to not
take action at all and so people get
stuck in analysis paralysis where they
have so many options in front of them
and they don't know what to do just pick
one and start moving you'll get way
further ahead universe not the right one
you'll adjust and the next move will be
smarter and better
you know I I missed out on a huge deal
early in my career because I was too
focused on having the perfect plan and
we lost like my first company we lost
out in a 40 million dollar deal because
I was too perfectionist and had to had
the perfect plan and then realized that
once I started executing the plan a lot
of my subjects were wrong in Hawaii so
would have been better just to get out
there and do so that's it it's just
starting like take some action today
whatever it is talking to a customer
going to a trade show letting a
partnership setting up a meeting
whatever it is just start and keep going
I was on a call yesterday with somebody
who is making a video for their channel
the youtube channel and he's like what
can you give me advice and you know I
want to do this content series and this
is one video many that I'm gonna make
and I want the first one to be perfect
and all this stuff and he's so worried
i'm making the first perfect video that
he's not doing anything and if you're
going to make a series just like in
business you haven't you're gonna have a
series of actions a series of steps
nobody remembers the first one like
don't don't put so much emphasis on
making that first video of that first
move perfect because you're gonna do
another one tomorrow and you do another
one tomorrow and it just gets lost and
what's way better is like you've already
missed out if you put that video up or
if you took that first step then you
could have already taken for more steps
for the rest of the week and instead
you're sitting there doing nothing so
just go take a small step say if it
works don't you able to take some big
huge risky step you don't have to go
sell your house and take out it you know
a huge debt to go start your business do
a small step but do it now do it with
courage do bravely and then take another
set tomorrow
that's it that's how you get started
eating when you look back and you look
at the successes of companies you'll
almost always find that it was never one
big huge thing it was just a combination
of little things with consistency over
time so that's what you need to do start
doing little things and be consistent
mm-hmm good luck and then I know you are
also someone who has had to really get
over the perfectionist turtles in the
process does that still flare up for you
because I found that I will have taken
strides and then I I start putting out
stuff and I don't get caught up in the
perfectionism but then there are other
times it can like Flair a pretty pretty
hardcore so do you still have to manage
that or have you kind of broken that
mindset down um not where it's really
important ah so I won't let it hold me
back from doing something that that is
an important move for my business or or
in life too there will be times that i'm
working on a pet project and I want to
keep adjusting to keep working and keep
getting the better but it's more of a
fun project than anything else that that
move from my first company that that
broke it you know like man that was just
a huge stupid mistake because I had to
be Preventionist and since then I
haven't really experienced that that on
the same scale so the only other the
only other time to think about it or
when it when I'm working something that
just feel really passionate about I
think about the 50 cent video that I've
talked about a couple times where it
wasn't I didn't meet my standards and so
I needed to go in even even even this
week who are we working on um who was
that guy little Wayne we're a little
Wayne video
it's coming out hasn't come out yet but
I you know I loved it the video was
great the research was awesome but I
wanted some bonus clips because he had
such a some people you know we struggled
to get the clips and sometimes we don't
like we spend a lot of time I'm working
on something and we don't release it
because we just can't find enough
quality clips but with him he had such a
powerful message I wanted to add some
nice bonus clips in there and so I went
and did the work search the bonus clips
and put it together because I want to be
proud of a video that I'm making I felt
that that video deserved it but the
others were also i feel like we need to
add bonuses in but we're also up against
the production's get the schedule and
and i don't have the time to go out and
do it so we put it up just the 10 with
no bonuses I'm still proud of the video
you know I wouldn't release something
that I don't like but could have been
better sure cuz it can always be better
right it can always be better whatever
you're making it can always be better
but since that first since that first
episode I guess I haven't really i don't
feel maybe I haven't it's subconscious I
don't feel like I've missed out on
anything major because of my
perfectionism mm-hmm cool yeah we we got
into some couple people joining chata
relaxing police station says hope you're
enjoying the game Evan HS and often
sourcebook I don't know if we shot it
out sherry yet but she popped in as well
welcome back cher 'I Love it yeah team
is great we have four kills one death I
have none of those all just got an
assist ha nice G rise killed someone and
I got an assist for that so good love it
alright next question is coming from
Alexandra
sontham oh yeah nice name on a sandal
all right on a son that o is asking when
I start my business how can I choose my
business partner and how can I motivate
them to work for me you know at the
beginning you don't have a lot of money
so it's quite difficult to hire someone
and I do not have the knowledge to do it
alone Thank You Alec cool so the
partnership aspect of your business
super important huge huge leap or it
because you know we've talked a lot
about how you can compare it to a
marriage and so if you're going to
choose someone to be your partner you're
going to make sure you want to make sure
that you have a lot of align values and
ideals for how you want to do business
and the impact that you want to make and
how you know how how that's going to
actually be executed you know I just
think it also to just going back to the
point about where you work for i mean in
some ways it's like any connection that
you're making whether it's your business
partner or what working for a company
you know if you can always choose a
place that you feel that partnership is
allowing you to be the oh this is so
cliche but you know like the greatest
version of yourself like you really feel
like the synergy of coming together
makes the two of you greater and and so
those are the types of partnerships that
I would think would be ideal where you
both are able to be uniquely you and
that will make the business I think
really be the most productive I also
know that you want to pick people who
are strong where you are weak so you
know what are the areas of your business
that you need for someone to kind of
fill in the gaps of it with their own
expertise
that they have and then in terms of
motivation we talked about this
yesterday that I think the greatest way
you can motivate people when you may not
have money right at the start is have
that that really clear vision and clear
values because people when they know
you're on a mission that they believe in
will be motivated because they're not
just working for you they're investing
in something that they believe in so I
think whatever is your business which is
doesn't stay here what it is make sure
that it's more it's more than just that
business like yesterday we're talking
about how stage is an accounting at the
end of you know it's an accounting
business it's more than that but they
are they have a mission much greater
than accounting which makes people who
have no interest in accounting want to
be a part of stage so I think that you
have to really be clear on vision and
values and mission I love it i agree i
would definitely not rush into anything
and in the way the way that may help you
know everything we she said plus it be
looking at doing some kind of trial
project to test so you know what is a
small version of what you want to get
done right like how can you start
working together on something and then
see if it's going to be a fit for you
guys or not it may work out maybe
amazing or as you get into any may
discover you know you have different
values you have different work styles
and it's just not going to be a fit for
what you want so I think that's uh it's
important yes you want to stand for
something yes you want to track people
who have the same kind of guys as you
yes you want to do a skillset analysis
and understand who you need to bring on
the team that is you know different than
you you meet the ops person even the
visionary person you need the sales
person you know whatever it is
and yes you may not be able to afford
having somebody coming right away so
partnership strategy can work but you
have to make sure that you're doing it
properly and a great way to do it is do
some kind of test project first see how
see how well you work along together in
the ticket something great and you want
to talk at all about that motivate
anymore oh sure yeah the second part for
motivating I like to hire and work with
people who are motivated by the work
that we're doing now you know some days
people can be down it's it's going to
happen you're not motivated every single
day is it going to be days that you are
down but if it's your job to constantly
motivate and constantly convince your
team that this is the right thing to do
that's that's not going to be a great
environment for every money like chances
are they're just probably in the wrong
role like it's not a fit for them so you
want to find somebody who is motivated
by the mission of what you're doing but
also doesn't need to have somebody
constantly saying oh you're doing a good
job you're doing a job we can do this we
can do this because that can be
exhausting for you you know you've got
you've got to run a business to you've
got to look after yourself and your
motivation as well and so I not a big
fan of working with people who
constantly need to be motivated by you
um I typically is just because they're
in the wrong the wrong position like
there's been times when you've been
really motivated and you've done amazing
things and then times when you haven't
been motivated and it's usually by the
work like I'm really motivated to help
entrepreneurs you know I make these
streams I make all these videos I pour a
lot of love into what I'm
doing that gets me up every morning and
I'm excited to go out and do it if you
had me you know sweeping floors or doing
something that I hate you know I'm not
gonna be motivated by doing that I just
not going to happen and so a lot of
times it just means they're in the wrong
position now you can still serve as a as
as a motivator right sometimes people
will be down just like sometimes you're
down sometimes people may need to be
reminded of the impact that they're
having sometimes people need to be
reminded the big vision the big picture
that you're working on but I highlight
this sometimes there because of its
constant than the purse is probably in
the wrong position mm-hmm I love it we
actually have a question from the chat
all right um yeah find it okay from
sleep safe from wheat station relaxing
sleep station asks about where is it I
thought I had it oh ok youtube collapse
is it okay is it okay to give your best
video to another or multiple channels as
well as posting on your own the global
audience growth yeah oh sorry you go no
no no no you go first or not this is
YouTube question what it say you tension
I love YouTube yes i do youtube collab
well i think it's very nice question on
on top of what we just talked about with
partnerships because you know youtube
partnerships to a certain extent are you
know that's what you're doing when
you're collabing and i think i think
that it's okay i think that you would
want to just make sure that your the
channels that you know i don't know if
you're talking about a network are you
in a network but I was
you know actually you're asking about
your one best video so you're not
talking about just creating content on
multiple channels but giving your best
video I don't see why there would be
anything wrong with that yeah because it
definitely will build your audience
quicker that is kind of a simple
straight forward to that any any reason
not to then I don't know what do you
think I'm a fan like every time I've
done a collab with somebody especially
if they have a bigger channel than I do
I don't always delivered I always go in
thinking how can I make this the best
thing that I can and if you're if you're
selfish and greedy and kind of hold that
back then don't expect to get amazing
results and I would also try to focus my
efforts i'm always creating better stuff
like make the next video you make the
best video oh we won huh we won the game
GG they surrendered hey Harry yeah ah
yeah my team was stomping and I actually
was purposely not doing anything to try
to delay it a little bit I was just
farming uh see how long we can make it
go but I still got an S well good GG um
so um yeah you know if I'm looking at
doing a club with somebody I always put
a ton of work into making it successful
again at the especially they have a
bigger channel than me because I want to
build that relationship I want people to
watch that video and then want to come
check out what I have i would also be
super engaged in the comments so
whatever video you know like as an
example Tim Schmoyer music guests
recently on his YouTube creator
entrepreneur my favorite it's called
thing and I was a sub for somebody else
because they were sick or away and and I
went in and I it was you know ten
o'clock at night
on a Wednesday I believe and I you know
did some research as to what the topic
was and got prepared was ready to go and
then was mentally like ready to bring
fire and then afterwards I was in the
comments and responding people who who
were thinking me or recognizing me and I
have the most of anybody of who's on
that call I have the most comments on
Tim's channel more than Tim more than
any of the other you know for people who
are there I left the most comments in
responses to the people who were engaged
and my chance bigger than Tim's right
like I'm how many subscribers do I have
I don't you know 400 something Thema is
like 100 something it's not even about
that it's nothing about that the channel
sighs it's just taking pride in the work
that you're doing if I doing work with
somebody else I want to bring the best
that I can bring and your best keeps
getting better right like what I can do
today is better than what I could do two
years ago when it's not as good as what
I can do in two years but every day I
just try to bring my best and so I'm
doing those collabs I would absolutely
try to be bringing my best to everything
that I'm doing try to promote the video
afterwards I would send it to my own you
know lists and it's you know tweeted out
of my accounts being involved in the
comments I would want I would my goals
like I would want that video to be one
of the best videos they've ever had on
their channel and I want to be
remembered like I'm motivated by impact
so I want you more teens to remember me
I want the Creator to remember me I want
them to have me back I want to want to
want to have me back for a second time
or a third time or fourth time so I
don't see a reason for holding back the
quality i would i would focus on
crushing it at that time and then crush
it again the next time
yeah I think that's great I think
there's something about being willing to
give your best for someone else's cause
too you know also just pride in work I
mean you wanna be proud of the stuff
that you create yeah no matter where
it's going mm-hmm you know even this
right like I'm distracted i'm trying to
play i'm trying to answer questions it's
a growth opportunity for me I'm sure at
least I hope that you know this episode
is better than the first one that we did
but I'm still proud of this series I'm
proud of what we're creating this is the
best that I can do right now will be
better any gear with this every day yes
but this is the best that I can do right
now I'm not I'm not mailing it in and
just saying oh you know it's just a
league stream whatever I don't care you
know I'm not going to try to answer that
question or I'm just gonna mail it in
just the best thing I can do right now
with the abilities that I have so the
intent and desire is there and so I
would focus on bringing that as much as
possible to every project you do whether
that's a collab or something for your
own channel step up the game be proud of
your work yeah yeah love it cool well
there's a pretty fast game too I'm uh no
yeah we even though I like it when you
guys when I kind of sad when you went
fast is it means we don't chat is look I
i agree i literally for the second half
of that game was not doing anything just
running around but i didn't get involved
I didn't get into a single fight I was
just running around just the tribe
extend it's also more you know why it's
more fun for me to not just about the
winning but timo the way i play my
champion it's a late-game build like I
get stronger the later the ink goes on
uh and so in a short game we don't get
the chance to do much which makes me
feel like we want but I don't feel I
don't feel great because I didn't I
didn't I didn't have an impact right
impact you didn't have an impact I need
to have an impact uh so I don't mind if
the team comes back a little bit like I
want their team to play better and come
back because as we get later I'll be
able to i'll be able to stomp so anyway
I've done that I did that to Jay before
I don't know i think i think it was on
the stream no i don't think was on the
stream I think was on his birthday where
he was it was over here we were playing
uh and he I was cheering for our team to
lose at the start cuz we got so far
ahead that I was cheering for our team
to lose and every time one of our
teammates died of like yes oh my god now
partly also you know as a joke but uh
right we still won I wouldn't get it let
it get out of hand that we wouldn't win
but I want that time so I wanted to drag
out a little longer so that I can make
my place so awesome yeah yeah he just
wanted to win and then get on to another
game that's his thing is likewise tallit
out this plate of the game let's let's
win fast and do it again all right cuz
impact impact I am advocating with
having zero impact that's me cool well
uh message to lead people I yeah I guess
just really loving the message of
valuing the work that you do just for
the gift of the work and you know
operating from a place of from there
like I'm motivated because I want my
work and the value that I put out to be
good not enough for any other reason but
I can be proud of what I put out that's
a good that's a good message cool I want
to i need to apologize to Martin cuz I
didn't really do much of what he asked
because it was doing in this game so
Martin next next game tomorrow I will do
my best to actually apply the lessons
that you taught me well thank you guys
for watching hope you enjoy hope you got
some wisdom there to help you with your
business we had a fast game and got a
quick win and I hope you guys have a lot
of quick wins today in whatever you are
doing carry our victory and energy
forward into your business and have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is I will see you
soon